omar bienvenida vamos a hablar entonces
de estos récord de roger federer para
empezar a federer tuvo durante
trescientos diez semanas el número uno
del mundo y eso para su momento fue un
récord luego superado por novak djokovic
y el otro y el digamos el más importante
de la carrera de federer son esos ocho
títulos de wimbledon que nadie tiene
tantos títulos sobre el césped de
londres como el aparte también está en
el tope del usopen con cinco títulos
pero si comparte ese récord con otros
dos jugadores estos dos jugadores que
son djokovic y también rafael nadal ya
se retira roger federer nadal nadal no
ha estado como quien tan buena forma por
sus fijaciones de musculares de espalda
también qué pasa con estos otros
jugadores del tenis no cómo van a ser
recordados también nos han retirado
estos 2 pero federer ya sí es una época
dorada del tenis donde en la que tres
jugadores se repartieron 63 títulos de
gran slam entre los tres es hoy que es
una época de probablemente 16 17 años en
la que tres hombres dominaron el tenis
de manera que
es difícil decir cuál de los tres es el
mejor de la historia porque en su
momento por ejemplo john mcenroe
coincidía solo con jimmy connors o
sampras rivalizaba con andrea agassi
pero digo y estaba más disperso el
protagonismo en el caso de ellos tres
son tres figuras enormes 22 títulos de
gran slam para nadal 21 para djokovic y
20 para federer como llega ya para
finalizar nuestra conversación un mar
federer hasta hasta este punto como
estaba haciendo su desempeño el tenía
bastante tiempo más de un año sin
competir había anunciado en su decisión
de regresar en varios torneos pero tuvo
que repetir una operación de rodilla que
era definitivamente la lesión que lo
tenía fuera del circuito repetirla
varias veces hasta que como él mismo
dice entendió el mensaje de su cuerpo y
pues decide dar este paso al costado